we were also in school
the same time that boys to men are
becoming Boys to Men so
it's literally like they're in the
bathroom harmonizing and you know they
won every contest they would like cheat
and put like glitter in their hands and
do something like that and girls would
be like and I'm like
no fight Nate sheets and Calculus class
like you're falling for that like all I
have to do is have some glitter in my
hand man do that Michael Jackson
three-handed Point yeah yep dude I did
it for a while in my monologue on The
Late Night show killed every time it
works in comedy too so we were I mean at
that time if you were an extra
on a unmentionable Philadelphia comedy
icons number one rated show you went to
the school right uh
every person who's a jazz God now went
to the school so we were like invisible
and even with the pedigree of like yeah
I've been playing with my dad since I
was five years old my first gate was
already like first day of school Miles
Davis is in my school
uh picking one of the kids to be his new
keyboard player because one of his guys
has a drug happen it has to go to rehab
so you'll you'll fill in Joey
Defrancesco at the age of 16. like
that's just how it was so we you know we
graduated and now it's like well okay I
guess I gotta live my dad's dream and
audition for Juilliard so
I auditioned for the new school and for
Juilliard in around like 92. Tariq just
you know it's a free trip to New York so
he comes with me we're on a train ride
back home
and this is somewhere out of uh either a
gray Poupon commercial or that last
scene and Dumb and Dumber
the world's most beautiful woman it's
always a beautiful woman behind this
thing
and it's a slow motion walk
yep to me now here's the thing the
previous year
uh is when Boys to Men started to blow
up they had it they had they came out
the box with a single called Motown
Philly and of course they're you know
calling up their high school friends hey
be in the video whatever so they asked
me to play drums in that video so you
know I've milked those 1.99
wait let me rephrase it Tariq milk those
1.9 seconds because literally like after
the video became like heavy rotation on
MTV
we'd be ready to go out for whatever and
he'd just look at me like what are you
doing I'm like what he's like come on
man put the shirt on I was like come on
dude it's like the same shirt yes that's
higher summer I had to dress in the
exact outfit that I yeah
no it's true
I'd have had a t-shirt made that would
say or I'd wear a hat that'd say yes I'm
that guy from one minute 32 seconds the
entire summer of 1991 I'd have to put on
the hoodie that dingy ass t-shirt those
OshKosh B'gosh uh uh thing and walk up
and down south street we would do like
nine rotations and you know wait ain't
you there oh my gosh and Tariq would
take their numbers down on everything
and that's literally like our social you
know the way your staff is holding their
hearts right now yeah I feel like such a
dweeb anyway not at all
anyway so
it's a year later and nothing is more
painful than the slow oh yeah dim fate
of like you know Al Bundy's always
bragging about those like four
touchdowns at polkai like I didn't want
to become that guy but suddenly I
noticed like oh the Magic's not working
anymore like
it's not working there's no glitter in
my hand anymore
so the world's most beautiful woman
walks up to me and Tariq and she's like
you're the drummer and the Spike Lee
Levi's commercial right now there's a
guy there's there's a bucket drummer the
guy that pioneered the idea of when you
see Street musicians bucket drumming his
name is chocolate he's from DC he moved
to New York and he was you know playing
buckets and whatnot and Spike Lee saw
him and put him in a Levi so now he's
the new drummer of the moment like he's
in the Mariah Carey video and I'm a
little jealous like oh damn you're like
those are buckets I gotta find a new
team
so she's like are you the drummer
and Spike Lee Levi's commercial and I
was like
no oh I'm not that's where you and I are
different
I just said yes I am and you are a black
thought
and just and just like that commercial
in Dumb and Dumber she's like oh
okay and she walks back and got off the
next stop and Tariq was just look like I
felt the you London idiot he
kept right he kept writing the whole
time calling my people
and next day
where uh we crashed in my parents crib
living room next day Soul Train's on
the commercial's on and then that
becomes like our our Doc Brown flex
capacitor sitcom sort of like
you look at each other and why don't we
do that like literally that commercial
came on it's like well why don't we do
that and literally an hour later like
we're and grabbing buckets and
everything sneaking out and we went on
South Street if we didn't make 120 then
it would have been a one-time only thing
but in like two hours like we're rich
and our whole thing was like 60 for you
60 for me this is date night money you
can buy a quarter pound of turkey some
bread steal some uh condiment packages
and that's a date you know make your own
sandwich yes we we go to like the park
or whatever and yeah
oh my God
if you're from Philadelphia if you're
from the Tri-State Wawa is a religion so
for five bucks you can buy like a half
gallon of lemonade a whole bunch of
turkey meat some pepper jack cheese some
bread and still the condiments and I'm
writing this down right
me now at my age excuse me there young
lady
oh and Questlove has given me the
following lists and I have all these
items
right so you would you would you would
do that no and that was like romantic
and movies were cheap back then if you
see it before 6 p.m you can see the
matinee for like you know whatever 2015.
that was Date Night money so we were
like hell yeah we're doing this again
told my friend about it the next week
and he's a bass player in my jazz class
and he's like well you guys gonna do it
again I was like yeah he's like well can
I join you guys sure now he drives I
didn't drive he drives with the station
wagon his dad station wagon he shows up
and he has his upright bass in the back
and I'm getting my buckets he's like
well dude I got the station wagon so
get your real germs and I was like oh
man my dad will kill me man I can't do
that he's like well he's not home
I said yeah you're right so Snook
uh you know very stealth operation of
you know putting uh loading my drums in
the in the in the station wagon and
that's literally how the roots were were
born